- [Announcer] TGI Friday's,
the restaurant synonymous
with classic American staples
like mozzarella sticks
and loaded potato skins.
A dining oasis in suburbia.
But what if the original concept of
TGI Friday's had nothing to do with that?
Enter Alan Stillman.
- My name is Alan Stillman,
and I founded TGI Friday's in 1965.
- [Announcer] TGI Friday's
started not as a restaurant,
but a place to mingle.
- [Alan] The concept came about from
being about 28 years old and
looking for a place to meet
as many good-looking women as I could.
- [Announcer] It was New York
City and the year was 1965.
TGI Friday's came on
to the scene as one of
the world's first singles bars,
because back then, it wasn't
easy for singles to meet.
- [Alan] The technique at the
time was that during the week,
people would make phone calls.
They would organize with a group of people
and you would all end up at
different cocktail parties,
which basically is what TGI
Friday's was meant to be,
a cocktail party that you
didn't need an invitation to.
- [Announcer] Whether it
was a sound plan or not,
TGI Friday's blew up almost instantly,
attracting more singles
from the neighborhood
than anyone could have ever imagined.
- [Alan] I was there
one evening tending bar
and one of the waiters
came up to me and said,
"Listen, there's half
a dozen people outside
that want to come in, what do we do?"
I walked out from behind the
bar about a half an hour later,
and there were 20 people
standing out there,
so we may have created the first line in
the history of the restaurant business.
- [Announcer] Alan came into this with
no hospitality experience at all.
- [Alan] I would say less than none.
I had a very inventive job, I
was selling perfumes at Flavors.
- [Announcer] Alan became
so popular that Tom Cruise's
character from the movie Cocktail
was loosely based on him.
- [Alan] His character
sort of was imitating
what we had done at Friday's at the time.
He was trained with flipping bottles
and drinks much better than I was.
- [Announcer] And when he looks back,
Alan's proud of what he created.
- [Alan] It was certainly
as fun as anything
that you could possibly imagine.
It was really something
that was quite special.